that's my that Joe Jonas putting his own
spin on X Taylor Swift's hits lover as
he serenades his brother Nick that's my
[Applause]
now we kind of love that Joe did this
mostly because it further proves there's
no bad blood after the pair dated well
over a decade ago and we know that they
didn't have the best breakup back of the
day there's one that's about that guy
huh that that guy's not in my wife
anymore unfortunately
no yeah Taylor put him on blast on The
Ellen Show at the time we haven't talked
since actually so it's like yeah but you
know what someday I'm gonna find
somebody really really great who's right
for me when I find that person that that
is right for me and is he'll be
wonderful and when I look at that person
I'm not even gonna be able to remember
the boy who broke up with me over the
phone in 25 seconds
[Applause]
sorry Oscar
but even tailor revealed earlier this
year that that was one of her biggest
regrets probably when I like put Joe
Jonas on blast on your show that was too
much wasn't yeah that was too much okay
I was 18 yeah
we laugh about it now that's good that
was you know the-- yeah yeah just
alright teenage stuff there we should
also mention that both Joe and Taylor
are seemingly super friendly now I've
moved on
I'm sure Taylor's moved on and it feels
nice and we're all friends it's it's all
good and they both definitely found
their own new lovers Joe married sophie
Turner and Taylor is dating Joe Alwyn
[Music]